And so we've covered a lot of ground today.
We've covered the optimization philosophies, optimizations
across textures, materials, meshes.
We've talked about the different view modes
that you have access to in the editor,
and also some tools that you can use
for trying to really reduce some of that content
that's being displayed on the screen
that you're trying to get performance from.
So thank you for checking out this course today.
Hopefully you found some at least useful pointers
in the directions that you can head
to start optimizing your content.
Maybe you've uncovered some tools
or maybe some material functionality
or some level of detail functionality
that can really help get some big wins
from your target platform.
So again, coming back to this philosophy,
you want to be doing this continuously
throughout your project.
You want to know the target platforms
that you're trying to hit,
and so you can make the different affordances.
Again, it's hard to say what specific set of parameters
you should be clicking.
It's going to be very per project,
but at least hopefully that presents some tools
to get you started on your optimization journey.